mathieu mon chéri parce que je peux rien
notre magnéto moi bien sûr mon chien
légèrement voyons maintenant c'est une
autre histoire d'amour elle de +45 ans
elle l'a aidé union il a compilé voilà
tu peux appeler ça une histoire d'amitié
une histoire d'amour une histoire
d'amitié amoureuse appelle ça comme tu
veux mais résultat est là ces bourses
quarantaine d'années que tu es très
riche tunisien
[Musique]
qui sait
turquie
d'accord il existe elle est vraiment
d'autres façons de ceux qui tueraient
quelques éclats de verre aurait
peut-être
[Musique]
décider les serrures
on peut se faire
[Musique]
amour pour moi souvent
parce que
[Musique]
m
autant
que je
je
ce sont
doit-on
j'aimerais jouer avec ton portable et
ont filmé
je vais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir que vous devenez les gars taylor
24 des tons directs bien sûr et il ya de
l'amour sans enlever moi ça derrière c
est vraiment un connard je vais te dire
quelque chose a dit il on s'engueulait
souvent enfin ses réponses m mais malgré
tout je suis ému quand je vois ça
m'angoisse de combat je te fais un
vagabond venu
[Applaudissements]